[Musique]
le 18-20 france info jean françois et
killing bonsoir à vous à patrick mignola
bonsoir jean françois qui dit emmanuel
macron veut aller vite sur la réforme
des retraites at il raison de vouloir
s'y attaquer dès maintenant alors que
nous traversons vous savez une crise
énergétique et économique majeure c'est
précisément parce qu'on traverse de
lourdes crise qu'on a besoin de
continuer à réformer le pays at on
besoin d'une réforme des retraites oui
comment faut-il la faire en atteignant
le plus grand consensus possible et donc
il s'agit pas de mettre la poussière
sous le tapis et se dire que parce que
les choses sont difficiles ne faudrait
pas les faire en effet nous a besoin
d'une réforme des retraites en tirant
une conséquence simple nous vivons tous
un peu plus longtemps et donc nous
pourrions travailler tous un peu plus
longtemps mais si vous le voulez bien je
pense que dans cette réforme des
retraites si nous voulons atteindre le
consensus
t2 si on se fixe uniquement sur l'âge
évidemment nous aurons des grèves
évidemment nous aurons des conflits
sociaux parce que sur le fond personne
n'a envie de travailler six mois ou un
an si on parle que de ça ça marche pas
mais évidemment si vous voulez faire un
vrai consensus vous parlez de la
difficulté d'emploi des seniors parce
que pour travailler plus longtemps il
faut que les seniors puissent travailler
plus longtemps en effet et en france on
est parmi les pays qui font le moins
travailler les seniors vous devez parler
de la formation parce qu'on ne peut pas
travailler avec la même solidité
physique tout au long de la vie et donc
faut pouvoir changer de métier il faut
parler de la transmission c'est à dire
quand on arrive en fin de carrière il
faut que les dernières années de sa vie
professionnelle on puisse la transmet la
passe et à transmettre ses compétences
et donc travailler peut-être un peu plus
longtemps mais travailler moins
longtemps dans la semaine pour
transmettre un peu plus au tutorat des
jeunes arrivant vous que ce soient les
sujets de fond patrick mignola
l'hypothèse d'une réforme intégré aux os
budget de la sécurité sociale ce qu'on
appelle façon barbare le plfss c'est
aussi la bonne idée c'est le sait le le
bon moyen de la faire redémarrer alors
de ce que je comprends est étudiée la
possibilité
d'utiliser la loi qui existe aujourd'hui
qui a été votée par l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat en son temps
qu'est la loi touraine c'est à dire
modifier en fonction de ce que nous dit
le conseil d'orientation des retraites
la loi touraine on l'a en le rendant son
application un peu plus rapide
moi je crois qu'il faut qu'on soit tous
très prudent sur le sujet on peut pas
être dans un moment où on essaye de
mettre autour de la table au conseil
national de la refondation et puis dans
le débat public remettre les corps
intermédiaires dans la discussion et
vouloir traiter dans une forme de
rapidité ou de brut et la passage en
france forme de ce type en tout cas
c'est comme ça que ça pourrait être
interprété et donc si d'ici le plfss si
d'ici plfss budget de la sécurité
sociale si d'ici le budget de la sécu on
a la possibilité de parler du travail au
sens large du nouveau rapport au travail
dans notre pays tous les jours il ya des
gens qui m'explique sur le terrain que
ils veulent créer des emplois mais qu'il
n'arrive pas à trouver alors qu'on a
deux millions et demi de chômeurs
le télétravail est intervenue les
nouvelles générations qui arrivent sur
le marché du travail veulent trouver du
sens à leur travail on a besoin d'aller
au bout de la réforme de la formation
professionnelle qu'on a fait on a réussi
sur l'apprentissage en a moins bien
réussi sur la formation professionnelle
et ce sujet fondamental de aller si on
acceptait tous deux travaillé un an de
plus pour mieux financer l'école pour
mieux financer l'hôpital pour financer
la transition écologique pourquoi pas
mais dans quelles conditions
si on discute des conditions de travail
alors peut-être que paris doit
travailler toujours là j'entends bien
vite discuter selon emmanuel macron la
réforme doit entrer en vigueur dès 2023
c'est à dire là demain matin en quelque
sorte il l'a dit devant l'association de
la presse présidentielle il a estimé sur
la nécessité de dégager des marges
budgétaires pour d'autres chantiers de
l'école à la santé il faut expliquer
donc aux gens que c'est une réforme des
retraites pour financer d'autres
secteurs parce que les caisses sont
vides alors la première chose c'est une
réforme des retraites si vous entendez
bien ce que dit le président de la
république depuis des années parce que
c'est même pas lui qui le dit c'est la
réalité on se confronte à une réalité
c'est que comme on vit tous un peu plus
longtemps effectivement le système des
retraites et financier de retrait à 3,8
c'est la première chose c'est il faut
déjà servir des pensions
imaginez que dans trois ans quatre ans
et c'est exactement ce que nous dit le
corps on puisse plus payer les pensions
sauf à réduire les pensions on va
augmenter les cotisations personne ne le
veut donc il dit une réalité d'abord
c'est souvent le régime des retraites
ensuite corrigeant ce qui est mal fait
dans le régime les positions des femmes
des carrières hachées donc les carrières
des personnes les plus fragiles sont
maltraités aujourd'hui par notre régime
de retraite et puis ensuite c'est le
travail en général dans la société
travailler un peu plus dans la semaine
travailler un peu plus dans la vie si ça
peut permettre de financer la transition
écologique parce que l'argent pousse pas
sur les arbres bah oui le président de
la république il dit des choses simples
qui sont pas forcément simple à entendre
mais qui correspond tout simplement
l'arrêt lilas l'argent ne pousse ne
pousse pas sur les arbres ou dit patrick
mignola ce que le modem est favorable à
une taxation des supers profits
moi je vais vous dire une chose simple
le modem parce que les favoris à une
taxation des profits c'est magique en
profite on vit dans une société un peu
de poisson rouge au fond il ya quelques
mois la grande victoire économique et
social c'était que le président des
états unis la présidente de l'union
européenne s'étaient mis d'accord pour
qu'on ait une taxation minimale à 15 %
de toutes les entreprises sait on est en
france mais dans tous les autres pays
développés on a des grandes entreprises
qui payent de petits impôts et des
petites entreprises qui ont déjà six
pays beaucoup d'impôts mais si déjà on
appliquait la taxation des profits avec
un minimum pour tout le monde et que
même quand on est une grande entreprise
et qu'on peut faire de l'optimisation
fiscale on paye bien 15% de profits si
vous avez une taxation des profits vous
aurez nécessairement une taxation des
supers profits après qu'on ait une
solution parce qu'il ya effectivement
notamment chez les énergéticiens il ya
eu de fait un effet booster de leurs
résultats seriez pour et qu'on peut le
refaire pas on peut les faire participer
via un fonds de relance de la transition
écologique pour accélérer la transition
écologique pour qu'ils y consacrent une
partie de leur bénéfice particulier
exceptionnel de cette année pourquoi pas
mais surtout le gouvernement sur
l'accord n'allons pas avec un nouveau
débat en oublier un autre le débat le
plus important dans la durée et dans la
justice pour notre pays c'est de se dire
que toutes les entreprises quelles
qu'elles soient doivent payer les impôts
là où elles produisent de la richesse et
que l pays tout un minimum d'impôt si
déjà on faisait ça on aurait beaucoup
moins de difficultés à organiser la
justice et c'est la finance et dans ce
sera un des messages du modem j'imagine
partenaires de là j'aurais été pour
cette rentrée parlementaire bien sûr il
faut qu'il faut qu'à chaque fois qu'on
pense les impôts on les pense dans un
esprit de justice merci à vous patrick
mignola vice président et porte parole
du mouvement démocrate merci d'avoir
accepté cette invitation dans le 18-20
france à fond